c'est la vedette de la nasa depuis plus
de 20 ans mais ses jours sont comptés en
2031 la station spatiale internationale
sera entièrement détruite ça fait 22 23
ans à peu près que qu'elle tourne autour
de ces de noter qu on a des images qu'on
a des contacts avec les les astronautes
qui sont en place dans la station et oui
le fait de savoir quel va disparaître ça
fait un petit pincement au coeur quand à
la fois laboratoire flottant banc
d'essai pour nouvelles technologies et
auberge espagnole cette citation de 400
tonnes qui orbitent la terre à toutes
les 90 minutes souffre de deux maladies
incurables l'usure du temps et sa
monstrueuse facture annuelle il ya le
vieillissement qui ont ce qu'est le coup
la nasa
j'aurais pu quand même assez généreux de
21 milliards de dollars us dépensent
plus de 3 milliards pour l'entretien
les expériences sur la station spatiale
internationale
la station se trouve à 420 km d'altitude
à partir de 2000 27 elle va
progressivement s'approcher de la terre
jusqu'au point de non retour en 2030
puis en 2031 c'est la rentrée dans
l'atmosphère
la désintégration et la chute dans
l'océan pacifique au point nemo qui sert
de dépôt spatiale depuis 50 ans on va
jouer sur le fait qu'une partie de la
station va brûler dans l'atmosphère et
puis ce qui va rester va venir s'écraser
en fait à cet endroit là en plein dans
un cimetière en fait de satellite
la nasa était clair elle ne construira
plus de stations en basse orbite c'est
l'entreprise privée qui veulent faire on
passe de
un monde où c'étaient les agences
spatiales qui était celle qui concevait
et qui possédait les infrastructures en
orbite un monde où maintenant on va
devenir les clients
des entreprises commerciales une
demi-douzaine de projets se précisent
celui de blue origin est le plus
ambitieux c'est presque petit village
avec ses quartiers réservés pour les
chercheurs les astronautes et les
touristes le projet titre à nab est plus
modeste mais plus réaliste à court terme
et celui d'action planifie de se greffer
à la station existante avant de s'en
détacher évidemment la décision de la
nasa va transformer le programme spatial
du canada l'agencé spatiale canadienne
va devenir un client de plateformes
commerciales au même titre que la nasa
et les autres partenaires donc je vais
important pour nous de non seulement de
suivre leur religion mais de commencer à
nous positionner en l'absence quasi
totale de réglementation dans l'espace
la multiplication des stations
pourraient également créer de nouveaux
défis il va y avoir comme une espèce
d'autorégulation propre mais oui ça peut
être inquiétant parce que on laisse
l'espace encore une fois au privé puis
l'espace n'appartient pas où est le musc
de ce monde la nasa vient d'accorder
plus de 400 millions de dollars en
subventions à trois projets de
construction de stations spatiales privé
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal